I'm going to throw this back to my
summer camp that I grew up going to
because I loved summer camp so much it
was in brand Lake um which let's see if
it yes oh my goodness okay also would
happily die here this place this is
where my summer camp was which I think
this is the ground wait this is a
Baptist Church this is not the grounds
of my summer camp hold on a second we
could just go to my summer camp actually
I think oh my gosh let's go to my
Camp oh my God I'm going to cry my eyes
out yes
yes okay oh my gosh you guys okay I used
to water ski out of here
every morning okay oh my goodness yeah
so I would die here happily for sure
love a lake I love Lake Sports I love I
actually grew up water skiing as well so
I like love all that stuff so find me
here find My Dead Body here I'm just
kid